for women to accept the truth about
themselves
[Music]
it tells
us it's from a young age
treated like a queen from a guy yeah why
do you deserve that
you're just a regular you're like a five
that's amazing yeah if you're an eight
maybe
you're like a five to six like why do
you think you deserve princess treatment
and then and you're and you're not a
virgin okay you want to be courted like
one yeah okay
um that is so true
but what I don't understand men are
afraid to tell them to and women don't
want to hear the truth what do they want
women they don't even know we don't know
um
um I mean women want the top like 10 of
men to like them
to cater to them yeah yeah so they want
the it's like when they say I like I
like a nice guy they're talking about
that guy that's like kind of like he's
not nice and they like him and they're
like well if he'd be a little nicer to
me like that's what they're talking
about they're not talking about you Brad
like
dude you work at McDonald's like she's
not you can you could be a little bit
meaner yeah that's true yeah what type
of man do you do you date a lot do I
date a lot yeah I mean I date you date
yeah and what do you look for them when
you're dating what what type of man man
you date
you can't do it yeah yeah
um I mean I like guys that have
leadership qualities
um and I would say it's conservative and
have similar like values I would say
you um you seem so confident a man of
intimidated around you
no they're not afraid of you I don't I
don't think about it I think that's just
an excuse like women say when like men
don't like them right they're like oh
they're intimidated by me no no you're
just yeah
it's just yeah no an average guy can
beat you up I promise he's not
intimidated by you but it seems as
though the average guy is afraid to just
be himself around a woman
hmm
like you put on a front instead of just
being himself
you know here at one way around guy
you'll be himself say what he wants
whatever but when he with a woman he put
on
most of the time not all not all but
like a nice personality in order to get
the woman to like him
because they try to like be what women
want but it's
amazing yeah it's kind of like on my
show it's funny because sometimes guys
will say things to me and I'll be like
more like feministy and they think that
I'll like it because they don't know me
you know I'm like stop it I gotta go
stop it you would tell them that oh you
just said to yourself
uh it depends where am I at it depends
how
like if I go on a date and it's the
beginning of the day
I'll probably just ride this thing out
like I'll probably just be quiet and
never yeah right on a day speaking of
dating you should demand Pay of the
woman
the the man the man yeah and why is that
um
I I just think like most girls won't
respect you if you don't pay if you're
trying to split it but honestly like a
lot of girls you don't even have to take
on dates ask her girlfriend I know she
likes you enough she'll go on a walk you
don't have panty money
so you know you don't have to spend any
money How about if if the woman inviting
a man out to dinner
should she painted
um she should offer she should yeah I
think so yeah
um I don't really have strong opinions
on it well you know yeah where are you
when it comes to politics do you uh are
you more conservative in politics as
well yeah I'm like really conservative
oh yeah probably like
because I take things too far oh yeah
yeah are you more like your father or
your mother
when it comes to things like that oh
to my dad's slightly more conservative
and I'm even more conservative than my
dad oh really yeah yeah nice yeah like
my dad believes in child support I'm
like cut it cut it none nasiki nada
you made your bed lie in it stop it
that's right amazing yeah so your father
and mother would be a concerned to have
an influence on you as far as politics
yeah because if I take
it Jordan Peterson like understand
myself test or whatever right it says
like you have a 97 chance of being
liberal but luckily my dad anytime I
like started to go that way he would
just explain it to me right on so yeah
nice
who do you think of the Great White Hope
what's that Donald Trump
[Laughter]
my gosh I miss him I miss his tweets
yeah I yeah I mean
I don't have like I'm not like a
die-hard like Trump fan but I thought he
was a good president I thought
and I look at him as an Entertainer and
oh my God he was so funny he was so
funny do you agree with me and you know
how to call you know that that he was
the greatest president so far
oh gosh
um one of them I would say I don't know
enough about every single president yeah
I mean you know the one in my lifetime
like right in my lifetime yes you know
to follow Messiah you know who the
father Messiah is Right Barack Obama
[Laughter]
I put that because when he first ran the
black was like oh he's sent by God he
sent by God and then when he
disappointed them all of a sudden he
fell you know now he's the father
Messiah I was pretty young when all that
happened oh you were yeah I think I was
in eighth grade when he got elected so I
wasn't really no one was calling him the
Messiah at my school but we were in you
know I was like 12 right so it wasn't
and so did you vote for the Great White
Hope
the I didn't vote the first time around
because I wasn't that like I didn't
really have a strong opinion either way
right second time around I did yeah oh
okay nice do you think he'll come back
again
it's getting kind of old
I I hope so but
I think you could do it it's just like
how old is he's like almost 80 Now isn't
he
I think he's in he's like
73 74 75 somewhere in there
yeah I mean it's just like eight years
it's like or no another four years yeah
yeah if if you know he's healthy and
stuff yeah if ever we I mean if ever we
needed him we need him now yeah yeah are
you surprised I call him the Great White
Hope
you heard me say that before
so you you uh how do you feel when you
attacked online about a feminists and
people like that
funny I think of them as children
actually
yeah oh you're thinking of feminine is
that yeah they're mostly whales that's
like the biggest one I get
yeah because there's a clip of me going
around where I say no one looks good at
300 pounds and then it's like all these
whales as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible